when i the reason i the way that i met
simon was they asked me to be a guest
judge focus conan to be um
finally we'll be real here for a second
i'm speaking you didn't think
[Applause]
so if you guys don't like what i'm doing
if you think i'm out of control you can
push a button and shut me down
yes what happened to me at nbc
[Applause]
uh but where there's a time when you
snuck into the room to see what the i
sneaked into the room snuck isn't a word
conan and you went to harvard and you
should know that
snuck past and past part of sneak
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all i want is a big
[Applause]
my wife's always assured me that doesn't
matter
may i move closer to you or would you
rather i did not
you better not
i could never you get nervous
don't trust yourself hey
i don't [ __ ] you
yeah i'm actually uh really uh
incredible my skills are really uh
amazing
[Applause]
this interview is over
i probably shouldn't point out every
question
i ask you go down a certain
but i could ask you you know what's your
favorite thing about a rainbow you know
and you'll be like oh the color
i thought you were getting
this is really weird
you guys have gotten rid of the talk
show desk
you stuck me on a bench
and i'm all by myself
and it looks weird i'm looking at
nicholas cage's ass yeah
and i'm telling simon cowell about it
who's not impressed yeah
this is a weird tableau yeah yeah yeah
oh i think i just broke the couch you
just broke
i broke this house before
[Applause]
uh are you still with john stamos i know
you two have been going out for a long
time that relationship is it falling
apart yet what's going on
why cody
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
there's this movie coming out yes title
undetermined at this point chairman of
the board
oh
all right do something with that you
freak
i i bet the board is spelled b-o-r-e-d
quickly quickly
okay okay all right you ready yeah
let's go
the madness that i'm seeing
okay great okay get on big
[Applause]
keep it honestly keep it it belongs to
you oh you should keep it i just came to
get the uh
thing that conan stole from my dressing
room
all right i gotta plug this
i just touch your boobs
[Applause]
roll it back
[Applause]
and this is actually true there were
comments that they wanted like oh we
want her to be
more bosomy uh that was a bigger heart
bigger heart yeah but that's i'm talking
about frustrated nerds online i think
you look absolutely stunning and i'm
here to take dinner anytime
why are you not looking at me look at me
look at me look at me
look
what's this
[Music]
[Music]
i want this guy to reflect
[Applause]
pretty nice
oh my god
juicy and big
you have fantastic lobes thank you
told you conan
mine gets bigger if you just keep
a woman's hip right and then you take
the picture and you just start writing a
bunch of creepy [ __ ] about what he's
doing it's not like he went for side
boob he wasn't like like sliding up
no it's a total overreaction that's the
face someone makes when they're going
for side boob
i would think so you know
here he's got code is going for it you
know what it is right the thing was
exactly they can put in in post right
now they're going to put in bullets
[Music]
[Applause]
to have only one breast because it was
in the way with the ark with the arch
and the error is that true the original
they only had one breast yeah it was in
the middle to let them shoot a boat and
we had what did i add in
why did i add middle coner nope that's
not where it was
ben where was the breast
no but you know what i started to have i
had um yesterday surgery yeah no hey let
me finish my own sentences
and i am you're gay no i'm not gay
and you're going to spain no i'm not
going to spain how do you feel about
conan for real conan is cool man cool
he's a cool cool cool cool white boy his
jeans be tight though
these dreams do be tight
i mean damn look like conan in back
pockets touching right now ain't never
seen
we talked about this before he knows i
just can't stand him
are you retiring excuse me
i love him not really i do
i asked him if like if you just won in
six years most awkward start to an
interview i think
[Applause]
[Music]
like a tap on the ball might be as
painful as a punch in the ball is this
true
i'm glad you asked
a punch in the ball
is worse okay is much worse he's
wrong i've been tapped on the balls many
times
i find it pleasurable yeah why are you
looking at me like you don't know what
[ __ ] are boars oh divorce i thought
you said the horse no i said oh i said
[ __ ] you're both wrong i said horse oh
horn of course
this has never happened before where you
and i both misunderstand yeah yeah yeah
that's never happened in 26 years right
you're the one that [ __ ] that up
the man with the world what the hell uh
i'm talking to them we don't have to
have a giant camera three inches away
from them
everyone's too he's talking to him get a
camera in there
we already had get another camera
i've never seen you work this hard in
your life
here we go
this is awesome
[Applause]
you